people are very confused they're very
confused about our health very concerned
about our
planet everyone's looking for that one
magic goji berry that they can take so
that they can avoid
actually doing the hard work of eating
well every single day and sleeping well
every single night they don't want to
work out they just want to eat a goji
berry and be done with it
and so it's much easier to pin
all of our uncomfortable feelings on an
object
than it is to actually deal with the
actual problems
diana welcome to the show hi nice to
have uh
nice nice to have me nice to be here
thank you so much chris
it is nice to have you um your work is
at the intersection of nutrition
environmental sustainability animal
welfare and
social justice that is that's just all
of those are mine fields
and everyone's emotionally charged like
that's an incredibly
harsh war zone to exist in
that's right
look at the look the look of a ptsd
battle scarred
soldier there yeah i mean i think that
you know a lot of people will say uh you
know eating meat is wrong
killing animals is wrong right but you
can't have an ethical discussion until
you understand the nutritional
benefits that animal products have to
humans
especially people that don't have the
privilege to be pushing that away which
gets into social justice we can't be
telling the entire world that everyone
needs to
uh be vegetarian when there are so many
people that
are nutrient deficient and malnourished
and then when we you know look at the
environmental consequences of a food
system without
animal inputs that looks a whole lot
like
chemical agriculture which is a huge
problem right and so
when we when we look at you know
chemical agriculture
plant-based only foods those two things
are the
recipe for fake meat
uh you know absolute destruction
um of our soil health ecosystem health
and human health
so i try to tackle all of those things
because they're all so
intricately twined and so i want people
to understand all of those things before
we have a discussion about whether or
not it's okay for an animal to die
for us to live there's some entry prices
that you need to pay before we can get
to just the ethical question
because it's layered within other uh
other topics yeah that makes a lot of
sense
what does a a real food licensed
registered dietitian
nutritionist mean what what's that
it's my own um uh
term but basically most dietitians are
giving out information that they've
learned in school where
you know everything in moderation is
okay let's not eliminate any
foods from the plate it's all about just
portions
and um and if you want to go vegetarian
or vegan
then you know that's totally okay but
then when we start to talk about
eliminating processed foods oh no we
can't do that
so um you know so something like a
whole30 paleo keto type diet is
absolute blasphemy right but then vegan
or vegetarian
are totally okay um and so i call myself
a real food dietitian because i focus on
real foods and work largely with people
to fix their gut health and their
metabolic health or weight
by getting rid of ultra processed foods
you've got a new film which will be out
almost exactly 22nd
of november uh which is probably not far
off when this is going to go live so can
you give us
give us an overview of it yeah so i have
a book in film
uh the book came out in the summer of
this past year
sacred cow and the film took just a
little bit
more time to edit i wanted them to line
up perfectly but
it just wasn't going to happen that way
um
so the film i actually did some filming
in the uk
i went to the lake district and filmed
with james rebanks who
is sort of a celebrity shepherd there
and uh and he has a new book
out actually as well um so we went there
we went to a lot of other farms
and other food producers nutrition
experts and really put together
as detailed as we could um in one hour
and 20 minutes
so the book goes obviously much more
into detail but we're just trying to
explain
why meat is actually not
the main cause of diabetes obesity
and heart disease why nutrition studies
are completely
based on observational research
and not um they can't prove cause all
those studies
talking about uh meat causing health
problems are really based on just like
oh look this population ate meat this
one didn't oh it must have been the meat
when there's just so many other
confounding factors involved there so
humans have been eating meat for three
and a half million years
and uh it's much more likely as zoe
harkem says in our book that
modern foods are responsible for modern
illnesses
we also talk about the environmental
case for
raising animals in a way that more
closely
mirrors nature and we dive in and out of
the ethics argument throughout the film
so where the book is
very um scientific and linear and just
tackles one argument at the time um
that would make a probably a very boring
film and so
uh so i worked with some really smart
writers and editors that were able to
take all the footage that i
shot and turn that
into a really awesome film that's
awesome i i
always think this whenever anyone talks
about the
correlation and causation of stuff they
do in their life
but my mum even today said something
about this new magnesium
supplement that i've been taking so so
how's it affecting your sleep
i don't know like i it needs to have
such an unbelievable impact itself
for me to be able to work it out in
amongst the chaos of everything else
that's going on
and as you hit upon there like someone
that does or doesn't eat meat
is probably going to correlate with them
doing or not doing
a whole bunch of other stuff all that it
is is essentially a selection variable
and that selection variable will
probably be correlated with other
selection variables
they're more likely to cycle to work
they're more likely to be left-handed
and
and single and vote democrat and do a
blob you know i mean like it's a whole
host of other things
right so when they've done studies
adjusting for those things they found
absolutely no
benefit at all in um eliminating meat
from the diet so
and what we do know is that people who
don't eat meat especially vegans
uh much higher rates of nutrient
deficiencies or insufficiencies
and um that can express itself
in mental health as well as in physical
health what was the
particular studies that brought that to
light the one that's obviously been
controlled for
multivariate analysis there was one that
uh
looked at people who only shopped at
health food stores so
then you've got the people who are more
likely you know
they tend to have a similar lifestyle
right they're more likely to cycle to
work
or yeah yeah exactly
um they're less likely to be heavy
smokers and drinkers
things like that um so of the population
that shopped at health food stores there
was absolutely no difference
in longevity between meat-eaters and
vegetarians and then there was a very
large study
out of australia so it was about almost
70 000 people
and it took um it it looked at
all of the the meat versus no meat and
adjusted for
all of the lifestyle variables that they
could and again found
no benefit at all wow so meat eaters
and vegans live the same amount of time
well vegetarians vegans
we don't have a lot of data on
long-lived vegans because most of them
give it up within three months
um and there's never been a vegan
population
um we've never seen the consequences of
vegan babies being born to vegan mothers
and then trying to reproduce themselves
um but we do know that there are
nutrients in animal source foods that
you can't get from plants that
um supplementing isn't always um
adequate um there's a lot of reasons why
people
wouldn't do well without animal source
food so for example
um vitamin a is a good example of this
so
uh the form of vitamin a that's in plant
source foods is
beta-carotene and when we eat something
like a sweet potato or carrot that has
beta-carotene that's the orange color
our bodies need to convert that into
retinol so that's the
active form of vitamin a and about half
of all humans can't do that effectively
50 of the people listening to this can't
digest carrots properly
can't well they can digest carrots but
they can't necessarily
convert all the beta-carotene into
vitamin a and so could end up with a
vitamin a deficiency
which um is not so great for your skin
and your eyes
those little bumps that some people have
on the back of their arms usually
vitamin a deficiency
great source of vitamin a is liver or
any
animal source fat usually has a lot of
vitamin a
wow that's so interesting you say that
meat
has become a scapegoat what's that mean
so um people are very confused they're
very confused about
our health very concerned about our our
planet
um everyone's looking for that one
magic goji berry that they can take so
that they can avoid
actually doing the hard work of eating
well every single day and sleeping well
every single night right
they don't want to work out they just
want to eat a goji berry and be done
with it
right and so um it's much easier
to pin all of our uncomfortable feelings
on an object than
it is to actually deal with the actual
problems
um so a scapegoat is literally
something that would be the sacrificial
animal
where people would put their sins on it
and and sacrifice
it right and so um meat has
that was going to be the title for the
film and the book was
was scapegoat and that's because uh you
know cow farts are ruining the
environment
when that's absolutely ridiculous it's
uh fossil fuels it's consumerism
it's it's all the junk that we keep on
buying all that kind of stuff
um you know the the problem for our
nutrition
and and you know growing rates of
obesity is not
meat eating when you know you can get 30
grams of protein from 200 calories worth
of steak
which has you know b12 which has all the
essential amino acids it's the most
beautiful package
of concentrated nutrition for humans
uh and the most bioavailable easily
digested
food we have um and yet it's become
you know meat meat represents so many
things to humans
it's power and masculinity
and death it's bloody it's strong
um so especially young women are
easy prey for these vegan propaganda
documentaries because
um they're much more likely to feel
extra uncomfortable
with all of those messages um so a lot
of people i'm sure you've met people
that won't eat anything on a bone
right they don't want to they don't even
want to know or maybe you haven't
no they want to detach themselves away
from the fact that it was an animal
right so like boneless skinless chicken
breast okay because it's sort of like
tofu and you don't have to like think
about it having been an animal
and maybe even the idea of chickens
isn't as close to a dog where a cow
would be closer to a dog which is our
friend
not an animal or a child you know so
um so cattle you're cracking up yeah
it's funny
uh anyway so um so it just seems that on
the totem pole
of ethicalness of of meat of food
consumption
cows are at the bottom right they're the
absolutely
is cow the is cal like the rich white
man
of the the food group world probably
yeah and then you you know then it's
like chicken and fish you know
pescatarians or like i'm a vegetarian
but eat fish
and so you're like slightly more pure
right and then you know vegetarian
would be just eggs and dairy but then
vegan but then above that there's raw
vegan
and fruitarian right things that only
fall so you wouldn't eat anything that
might have been harvested and harming
things you would only eat
things that have fallen already so
that's a that's a diet that's a diet
that's based on
purely on gravity the gravity there's
dietary
right which would be uh if you are ultra
pure
then you only need air right so all of
this is
is absolutely ridiculous right but even
the idea that
eating meat is bad when humans
are biologically omnivores when meat has
been something that has been
that's why we have such large brains
right now it's because of animal source
foods
and so to be so um disconnected
from the fact that humans are animals
and that there is a biologically
appropriate food for us
um and that we are um intertwined within
a food web instead of
on top of it and controlling it and
dominating it is
um is really at the heart of what i talk
about it's our
um our denial of death i mean we even
see it in the
in the fitness world right like
longevity everyone wants longevity
um you you know it
it's it's not even quality of life it's
just how can i live the longest
you know how can i cheat death um you
know most americans don't have a will
we don't want to think about death we we
don't see it on a regular basis and we
don't
accept that it's part of the cycle of
life it's not just the end point of
everything so i kind of get through all
of that stuff in the book
more so than in the film but the film we
talk about it too do you know who
sheldon solomon is
okay so he's an expert in earnest back
his denial of death he was on the show
a couple of weeks ago and he's oh i have
that book i have it's on my food
politics book
uh bookcase which i didn't realize was
even a topic
yeah um denial of death fantastic
fantastic insight kind of a bit of a
heavy read i will it's not like
an easy one as you go to bed um i know
that you have
done your research especially for the
book and also subsequently for the film
i want to close one of the doors to hell
that we've left a jar there
about the methane argument what is the
contribution
of livestock to uh greenhouse gases
and greenhouse gas effect please okay so
there's there's a couple different ways
you have to understand it so this is a
little bit longer than um
yeah right it no big deal is is the fast
answer
um so two things one is
methane through biogenic sources needs
to be viewed
completely differently than from fossil
fuel extraction so
um i have an animation in the film and
an infographic about this
on my instagram feed and available on my
website but basically we show
the molecules being breathed out by a
cow so it's not cow farts actually it's
um belching from cows so it's how burps
that cause methane it's cow
birds well that cause
it's the bacteria in their stomachs
that's causing
um the methane right so they're breaking
down
um very fibrous materials
in an anaerobic way which produces
methane
okay so almost all of the food that
those cows would eat
if they weren't eating it would just sit
in a pile
and emit greenhouse gases if we didn't
turn it into protein
right so we just have to sort of talk
about that the grass is still going to
be there
um so when the cow breathes out methane
it goes up into the atmosphere it lasts
for about 10 years and then it gets
broken down
into h2o which is water which becomes
part of the water cycle which is rain
and then co2
which is taken up by the plants again
and uh they
br they respire oxygen which is what we
breathe in
and then the carbon goes down into the
ground
it feeds the microbes underground the
carbon becomes the grass that's what it
is the cow eats the carbon
um and it goes back into their digestive
cycle
some of that carbon turns into meat that
we eat some of it turns into poop that
uh fertilizes the ground again so it's
all these molecules are working
in if you could just picture the swirl
of bubbles
that's that's what a biogenic cycle is
okay
and there aren't really more cattle than
there were
wild ruminants before we sort of took
over and got rid of it so we don't have
more
belching animals um than we did
when we had like the bison in in the
you know 1500s before we went and killed
them all right
um so when we talk about fossil fuels
that is a one-way street so we're
extracting ancient ancient carbon
and methane that's been locked in the
earth's core for millions of years
and we're pumping it straight up into
the atmosphere so it's not
really circulating in the same way that
the methane from a cow
is being uh burped out
so does that make sense oh yeah it does
surely the the methane
the methane from both will break down at
the same rate though right 10
10 years or so yeah yeah it's not it's
different it's not that it's
going to be treated differently but
because there's no balance to the fossil
fuel equation
it just gets used and and blown into the
atmosphere it's extra carbon right so if
you picture like
if you were to picture one of those
little um
ecosphere glass things you know what i'm
talking about what are they called
biosphere is it biosphere right it would
be like the fossil fuels were pumping
in extra gases into that right because
they're being extracted
not from the biogenic natural cycles
that are already happening in there
it's from like way locked away carbon
that you know
is outside of that biosphere that then
we're going to be pumping in
and it's too much i'm blown away the the
main breathtaking takeaway from today is
that it comes from cow burps not cow
farts
like that that's just totally taken and
there's something about that as well
like even just in that little
example i think it shows that there's
something less icky or something more
ricky
about it being a fart that goes into the
air and slightly less sicky about it
being a burp i don't i don't know where
i
feel about that so you you said about
that there's and then there's a little
more to the story too so i can
let me uh so um just as far as the
emissions go like worldwide when
when we're talking about numbers and
you're hearing that you know uh
livestock are worse in the entire
transportation sector because that's
like a common
thing that people say that is actually
completely not true either so
globally cattle livestock in general
contribute about five percent
of all um greenhouse gases but again
it's part of a cycle
um transportation energy production
all of that is the lion's share of
uh greenhouse gas emissions and when you
were if you were to look at
global warming trends uh and co2
concentrations rising
it is lockstep with the industrial
revolution
and the transportation industry taking
off so
um it you know we don't cattle are not
the cause in any way of of
uh all the problems we have in the
environment now
um there are different ways to raise
them concentrated manure is a problem
um feedlots can be not great places for
cattle to be
although that they don't spend their
entire lives on feedlots are only there
for the last few months of their lives
so all cattle for beef start on grass um
guess what the uk is really good at
producing grass
um and you know i've i've been there
it's um especially when you go north
you don't have a whole lot of vegetable
production happening right
like there's just you have to import
most of the vegetables that
that are coming there especially in the
winter and um
but the great thing is grazing animals
thrive
in you know lush green pastures which um
you know is the ideal place for uh
you know them to be and not cropping got
you you so we've talked about
meat being a scapegoat who is it that
wins
when meat gets vilified
so the fossil fuel industry loves
that all the attention is on cow farts
and not on
gasoline and fossil fuels and and uh and
all of that right so they
love this um also the ultra processed
food industry loves it because
it gives them a pass so instead of
potato chips and
um you know junk food being the problem
it's just meat right so so if you could
just eat something that's meat-free then
you're fine
right it's just sort of like in the 80s
and 90s when it was fat-free
it was fine and we know that that was
completely ridiculous
um and so you know the biggest winners
though
are the beyond meat impossible foods and
all the money that's going right now
into
the production of lab grown meats so
there's big money there's you know lots
of stocks lots of hopes
placed on these alternatives
and i looked up the price of beyond meat
and one of those
burger patties is actually twice as
expensive as organic grass-fed beef here
in the u.s
but it's being pushed as something
that's you know cleaner nutritionally
better for the environment and oh no
animals died
but what we point out in the film in the
book is that there is no
food system where no animals die that's
impossible
because even in the production of
your pea proteins or your soy or your
wheat
tons of animals have to die in order for
that to be grown so
if you then can understand that no
animals die
i mean that there is no animal that
there is no
deathless system uh sorry that was a
hard one to get out
then then the only solution is to make
sure that the death that happened for
your food was done well
right um and so one large ruminant like
a cow can provide
500 pounds of meat
when if you were to equate a mammal to a
mammal so if a mouse's
life if a death to a mouse is as
traumatic as a death to a cow
you know if those two things are equal
then
clearly the solution if you're trying to
live a diet of least harm
would be to eat a cow because so many
rodents are killed in the production
of grains and um and other
you know plant-based proteins
yeah i want to loop back to the
philosophical discussion the ethical
side of this in a little bit i have a
good friend
alex o'connor who is a big vegan
philosopher coming out of oxford
and i literally was speaking to him
earlier on today so i
have a couple of things that he
mentioned to me but you've highlighted
something that's quite interesting there
which is um the polarity that most
people would expect when they hear this
is a book about me is this is a book
about not veganism
and it seems to me that you're primarily
opposed
to processed foods rather than
people who eat whole foods that are
slightly different is that right
and is the meat eater versus plant-eater
debate making us take our eye off the
ball
yeah so i mean it's it's we're arguing
about the wrong thing
um it's not meat versus no meat and um
i'm all for people to have their own
choice when it comes to what they feed
themselves
um as a mother and dietitian i do have a
problem with people
not uh allowing children to eat meat
because
that can cause some serious problems and
we've seen in the literature
like babies dying from uh being on a
vegan diet so
what are the what are the deficiencies
you get as a an infant from
primarily b12 which is required for
i mean a b12 deficiency can cause
permanent brain damage
and you can't just supplement that out
not necessarily
so there have been cases of vegan
exclusively breastfed babies two vegan
mothers
who were taking b12 and the baby died
from some downstream effective b12
deficiency that is terrifying yeah
um and another nutrient that is uh so
b12 and iron are two of the most common
nutrient deficiencies worldwide
it's really hard to get the iron you
need from spinach
or from plant-based sources um
b uh iron deficiency causes
um also well it causes stunting because
you need iron to grow
but it can also cause delayed
um you know learning problems and
there's only been one clinical control
trial a
randomized control trial looking at
children
and meat versus less meat or no meat in
their diets
and the group that got the meat
supplement
excelled physically behaviorally and
physically so we know that pulling meat
away from kids is not going to do
them as good as actually giving them a
little bit more meat
and so um you know that needs to be
considered when we're
having these policies like meat-free
mondays
in schools because they're based on not
no science
at all it's just you know it feels like
the right thing to do
we should just make our make those kids
not eat meat it really is difficult to
bifurcate the emotional component to a
lot of this discussion and i think
you know if if there was a as subtitle
to 2020
it's that like yeah i know there might
be some facts or
i don't know the facts but this feels
right mm-hmm
um definitely so yeah the world of fast
easy news
and a tweet which can be untrue but
reach a million people
i think sadly probably doesn't
necessarily help this situation
i mean there wouldn't be other shouldn't
be anyone that wouldn't get behind
processed foods free monday like
processed foods free monday would be
like that's probably not a bad idea but
yeah
meat whole foods wednesday i guess that
doesn't whole foods wednesday
i don't mind i'm all right with whole
foods wednesday what one of the things
that
i have seen promulgated a lot online is
we're already eating too much meat isn't
that the case no
oh it's not the case at all so most
people
aren't getting you know the the rda for
protein is way too low
um and i go through that in detail in
the book so it's a recommended daily
allowance here in the us i don't know
um what you call it in the uk
rda um so what is it over there is it
0.8 grams per kilogram
do you know uh e i don't know i think
it's
10 maybe 10 or 15 percent perhaps
of total diet of total calories i think
so yeah
which is way too low too so we have two
um
measurements here we have pounds per uh
grams per kilogram of body weight but of
course in the us nobody knows
what a gram is or what a kilogram is
right so
they do the math for you and they base
it on
an ideal body weight for women of 125
pounds which is way less than what i
weigh
and just way too low and for men 154
pounds
wow yeah i would be seriously
malnourished if i was eating
154 pound man eats right
and and the rda is the minimum not the
optimal amount
so it's a minimum for the light weight
for the skinny people
that don't do anything america's a big
america is a big country as well you got
something right
so the average american woman is 166
pounds the average american
man is 195 pounds so when you
then go okay 0.8 grams per kilogram
times uh you know what do we need when
we look at 166 pound woman
it's twice the rda uh-huh um
and then when you look at anyone who's
in a growth stage
so babies um children
adolescents pregnant women lactating
women
or anyone over 40 when we start to lose
muscle mass
they need twice as much protein so
really people are eating way under
the protein almost all age groups are
getting less than even the rda
of protein right now um and so
my recommendation is to at least start
at 1.6 grams
of protein per kilogram of body weight
which is
almost nobody walks into my nutrition
practice
even eating the rda of protein you know
and then wondering why they're so hungry
all the time and tired
and why they can't lose weight and the
magical thing about upping someone's
protein especially from animal sources
is they lose weight they have more
energy
they're full all day long protein is the
most satiating macronutrient
um and here in america we're only eating
about two ounces
of beef per person per day so that's not
like
these you know massive tomahawk steaks
every single night
but but that's what the perception is
we're clearly eating too much meat
and again that's based on an
environmental i feel like we're eating
too much meat and what that really means
is
i don't like what feed lots look like
it's gross i think we should stop them
and you know do something different
that's that's what
is actually like if you could do like a
thought bubble over someone's head
that's what they're thinking
um we're eating way more chicken than we
ever have before and chicken is less
nutrient dense than beef
and we're also eating twice as much
processed foods as
we did in the 1970s and so
we've seen our obesity and
diabetes rates soar because of this
we're eating less meat than ever
than 1970. um and
again and again when i increase
someone's
meat intake and i tell them like okay
why don't you i'll take a 160 pound
woman that wants to lose weight and i'll
say okay
how about you try eating 130 grams of
protein a day
they can't even do it they they're so
full and they think it's
so wrong you know but that's
that's what works that's that's my like
magical ticket now nobody has to come
see me as a dietitian because that's
like pretty much what i charge people to
do
guess what you need more protein eat
more protein and so do you and sodium
right everybody come in here we're going
to have a mega church sermon
everybody here needs some more protein
yeah i mean anyone who's ever tried to
hit
two grams per kilo of body weight who is
like un untrained or unused to it um
it's it's challenging like no one nobody
accidentally eats two
grams per kilo of body weight of protein
you would have to be just an
unbelievable
like ridiculous portion control person
yeah it would be insane
and therefore we heavily rely on
supplements so what
is or what are some of your best pieces
of advice for someone who needs to get
more protein in you've just identified
that
that you say 160 pound woman 130 grams
of protein
i can't get it in what uh
what are some of the ways that
stop laughing no no you laughter i can't
get it in first
and now and then i saw you laughing and
now i'm laughing
okay i'm changing how can we how can
people eat
this breakfast is the number one way to
get so if we can get at least just 30
grams of animal source food
animal source protein in at breakfast
that really sets the metabolism and sets
your
appetite for the whole rest of the day
so
um and surprisingly eggs are so low in
protein everyone's like well i hate eggs
and i'm like well who said you have to
eat eggs for breakfast
eggs but they think that that's the rule
right that's that's
that's the egg and cereal industry
telling us that breakfast cereals and
eggs are what you eat for breakfast
so this morning for breakfast i
had some meatballs i think and then for
lunch i just had like a big piece of um
uh fish uh with some vegetables on the
side so i'm not telling people not to
eat vegetables
i'm just saying if you if weight is an
issue for you
or if you don't want to gain weight
which most of us don't um or if you want
to put on some muscle
or if you want to have more energy
then consider increasing your protein
and it's a lot easier
usually people are not eating enough
protein in the morning
um with breakfast so it's easier to
think of
you know maybe eating like six ounces of
um
steak or pork or chicken or something or
fish with
lunch or dinner but for some reason with
breakfast people are thinking
oh i just want a little piece of toast
and you know no meatballs
whatever what else can we do on a
morning because i you know
it's i'm a fan of meatballs but i can't
see me having it every morning for
breakfast
yeah sausages um leftover steak from the
night before
i'll make eggs but i'll put a ton of ham
in them
um a little bit of cheddar cheese that's
a good source of protein too
um i'll i eat fish a lot
and or some people like um
you know just sliced turkey with you
know like in a lettuce wrap for
breakfast
with a little bit of pesto or something
there's there's so many ways to get it
in i mean it's just real
really meal one not breakfast so if you
think meal one meal two meal three
um it doesn't have to be you know eggs
and bacon or
as your only like meat based breakfast
option yeah that fits for me as well i
tend to go
faster until around about midday just i
don't like training on a full stomach
and i tend to train in the morning
so for me i'll then like kind of
condense that afternoon down so that
very much is kind of like
like early lunch late lunch nearly
dinner
early dinner dinner bed like so the the
it is meal one two three four um what
about meat and cancer
doesn't increasing in increasing our
meat consumption
increase our risk of cancer not with
fresh red meat
they did find a little bit of an
increase with bacon
but your average chance of getting colon
cancer
with um in the general public is five
percent
out of like people right if you were to
eat five slices of bacon every single
day for the entire rest of your life
your chance goes from five percent to
six percent
okay but the media reports that as a 20
increase oh my gosh
it was actually 18 increase but that
but that's still not even twice that's
not even
50 the risk that's it's it's
statistically meaningless um to go from
five percent to six percent there are so
many other
great ways to avoid getting cancer like
don't smoke
exercise uh eat a a mostly
unprocessed food diet in general um
you know anyway so in the context of a
good diet and a good lifestyle i see no
reason why people
should be avoiding processed meats um
either what about cholesterol are your
cholesterol's bad and
meats are bad and i don't even know what
mine is but i don't want cholesterol so
right um i go into it in depth in the
book
and it's interesting because um you know
a lot of the
hysteria has just been debunked so many
times about cholesterol
it's actually taken off the nutrients of
concern of the us dietary guidelines now
wow um but quietly uh so that didn't
make too much slow retraction yeah
but yeah um so you know we're less
afraid of fat these days
so butter is now you know kind of making
a little bit of a comeback actually
butter sales during covid
were through the roof better than ever
before i think because a lot of people
were home baking too
so that's not necessarily um you know
always a good thing
but meat is worse than butter could
right because it's it's not only gonna
kill you
but it's also bad for the environment
and it's bad to kill an animal
right so the anti-meat thing is way
worse than the anti-fat thing
because we didn't have you know
anti-butter people
marching around and you know
[Laughter]
going after butcher stores and
destroying property
and issuing death threats to people that
promoted butter
right but that's what's happening uh
with the meat movement right now is the
anti-meat folks
and we touch on that in the film we show
a story about a butcher shop that was
being harassed
um and actually has to have a sign
permanently in their window now about
um how you know there is no such thing
as an ethical slaughter
um animals have died for your food you
know stuff like that
um it's it's absolutely crazy and
um you know unfortunately these fringe
groups tend to attract people who
already are uh maybe not
totally thinking logically but then when
you get a b12 deficiency on top of that
from being vegan then you get some
really radical behavior
um and so you know it's it's
it's been really interesting for me to
see how
this all gets expressed yeah it's
fascinating for me as well i mentioned
earlier
on my friend alex um who is
one of the best thought through vegans
the the single best thought through
vegan i've ever met so
he hasn't gone from an emotive
perspective he goes from a philosophical
perspective
in that he thinks minimizing suffering
is something that we should all do
um and if i was to dig into if i was to
still man his argument versus the mouse
argument that you meant made earlier on
i think that he wouldn't equate the
suffering of a
mouse to the suffering of a cow now
again volume of how many earthworms and
everything else is dug up versus
killing a cow all that sort of stuff
alex needs to be here to kind of defend
himself my point is that
he yeah he's stood out to me uh because
of how robust
and well-grounded his understanding was
he spent hundreds of hours
debating people in the oxford university
halls and pubs around there um to ensure
that his
stance was robust enough for him to make
the lifestyle change
he didn't want to go vegan but he felt
compelled to because of something
philosophically
now that was surprising to me
because that appears to be a rarity and
if
everybody was coming up to me and saying
hey man like here
is my incredibly well read very well
grounded
calmly beautifully articulated reason
for why i think
that veganism is the lifestyle for me
i'm like yeah i can have a conversation
with i enjoy having a conversation with
him
having pig's blood thrown on me because
i own a canada goose
doesn't feel quite the same and that's
got nothing to do with diet
yeah yeah there's definitely ways to
intelligently engage people
you know your friend should probably
read this book written
by andrew smith out of drexel university
um it's called a critique of the moral
defense of vegetarianism
so he is a philosophy professor phd
he was an ethical vegan
and he started writing a paper on why
he was vegan and it turned into a book
where he talked himself out of it
i did a podcast with him a while ago
maybe three years ago so his name's
andrew smith
um i did interview him for the film and
his interview didn't make it in
only because we had some other stronger
stories
that the editors felt were better
but i do when we do the global release
of the film
people are going to have an opportunity
to purchase the extended interviews and
his is one of it
yeah that's cool yeah so my pushback to
that argument
would be who are you to say
that just because an animal is larger
it's life is worth more
like what is the criteria of life being
worth
more or less than something else would a
zebra be worth more
or would a giraffe be worth more because
it's physically larger
would that mean that you know you are
more important than me because i'm
smaller
you know like where is where is that
where do we go with that
or you know a 300 year old maple tree
that is the habitat for hundreds
um of little critters and insects and
you know providing food
for for and shelter
because that's a plant would the death
of that tree be
less important than the death of a field
mouse
right um so where do we draw the line
between
like the difference between ecosystem
function and health
and individual lives and how do you
equip
you know what why is why on earth would
a mouse be
less important than a you know or a
colony of bees they're really
intelligent
right but you know so is spraying
insecticides okay
you know and if it isn't okay then how
are we gonna produce food without
insecticides
oh we need animals but then
how are we gonna i feel like i'm on the
princess bride
how are we gonna how are we gonna you
know
use animal inputs to grow kale
if no animals can die what if an animal
dies do we put it in the compost
or do we just like leave it in the woods
it's gonna compost in the woods too
should we just you know like how what
where do things end and other things
begin and
the reality is we're all just molecules
being recycled into other molecules
right like that's that's all we are um
which gets some of the very religious
people very frustrated with me but
that is the truth and and so
you know we have to just be looking at
you know how do we
increase the biodiversity how do we
increase the quality of life
what's your opinion on the carnivore
diet
i think it can be a great tool for
someone who
has really messed up guts
and has tried a lot of other things and
it hasn't worked um maybe people with
extreme autoimmune issues things like
that
although i think um as a lifestyle like
just for someone who
wants to try it out because it's cool or
you know just as a weight loss thing i
think people should be eating as many
foods that don't give them as pro
problems as possible in the mo try to
get the most nutrient density we can
through food
and um so as a clinician i've used it
with patients and with amazing success
with um binge eaters sometimes just
restricting it all the way down to just
me so they have no other decision
is really actually quite helpful
amazingly
um and i've seen so many more binge
eaters during covet than i've ever seen
before
um so why do people comforting
themselves with food
yeah i mean binge eating tends to be
something that comes out of
people feeling that they don't have
control and i think it's really hard to
feel like you have control over anything
during this time
yeah so and then also i mean just if you
have
an emotional um
issue with food a distorted relationship
with food
having 24 7 access to your refrigerator
is not a good thing
right humans i saw this meme at the
beginning of the summer
that said and it was a note posted
inside of the fridge
and it said you're not hungry you're
just [ __ ] bored
yep yeah yeah yeah i actually had it i
saw another
cartoon saying that um the fridge was
sentient
because it's calling your name you know
um so no other animal has to go around
saying oh i've had enough
i can't possibly eat i better stop
eating all those coconuts
you know like all animals are wired to
seek out food um as diverse as possible
uh so that's called optimum foraging
strategies an awesome paper written
about that
um so humans are wired to you know eat
some of these berries but then you kind
of get a little like full
on those but then there's always room
for those berries right because those
ones are
they have a different nutrients in them
um but
so when we're confronted with all these
nutrient poor processed foods that
stimulate us to overeat we have no
off switch for them it's very easy to
see why people
are overweight um and it's really not
their fault it's
it's we've engineered ourselves into a
really
disturbing relationship with food the
arms race is incredibly unfair
i learned the word orification at the
beginning of this year which i think is
the design
of the texture of foods and one of the
examples a couple of examples that were
given is that um
ancestrally it would be very rare for us
to come across a food which had multiple
textures in it
like you get a bunch of berries they're
kind of slimy you get some kale it's
also kind of slime you get some meat
it's kind of like a little bit more
tough and chewy and
you get something that's been out in the
sun and it's dry and crispy or whatever
um
but if you look at most foods
that are really weaponized for
overeating
like fries or oreos
there is a contrast to the texture
crispy on the outside and fluffy and
light on the inside
and that helps to bypass obviously
another one of them is the balance
between carbohydrates and fat and fat
that tends to be in there as well which
is why cheesecake is such a
bastard that's my favorite because
you've got this you've got the
buttery biscuit base and then you've got
the cream on top and then you've got the
the tanginess the sweetness of the jam
so you can sugar and fat and then a
little bit more carbs at the bottom
like it's hard it's hard to say no um so
we've
that's the stuff we shouldn't be eating
what are the rules
that i can follow so that i make sure
that i get good meat i go to the
supermarket tomorrow or i go shopping
online tomorrow what do i do
um you know i i if
there's two things you know one is for
health right so there's not a
massive difference uh in nutritional
quality between
a totally grass-fed steak and a steak
that was finished on a feed lot
um and so even if you don't have a lot
of money your
your best money is spent on the more red
meats than
chicken or pork um just because
nutritionally
it's just a powerhouse right oregon
meats are going to be a really good
choice for you
um when we're you know local fish
um i love fish i actually prefer the
taste of fish to
to meet um it's all just animal flesh
though i don't know why we like say like
meat
everyone you're from boston right or
you're in boston yeah yeah um
everyone i know from boston absolutely
adores
seafood and everyone i when i i went out
there and i got taken for a
row some sort of role with lobster
yeah with lobster like shredded in it
yeah
and covered in butter yeah
you've never heard of a lobster no
british what do you think we have over
here fish and chips battered fish
chips and weak tea that's what we've got
over here
uh yeah lobster roll is pretty well i
didn't actually grow up here
um but but yeah i love the i love fish
and and when someone comes you have to
take them out for
a lobster roll that's what you do or
clam chowder yeah that's nice to see
what happened to me
uh-huh um so uh so i highly recommend
that um folks just try to get food as
close to the source as possible
if you have the opportunity to go find a
farmer to buy your meat directly from
them
um and that's not not always an option i
know in iceland they couldn't do that
because of government regulations
like they had to sell it they it had
like all had
the government set the price for lamb um
so uh anyway i just um
you know as much as you can support
local farmers you know buy
you know british beef british lamb not
the imported stuff
because that's what's keeping the
british landscapes beautiful is the
farming culture there
and um i saw a big divide between
like city and farming um you know urban
and rural when i was there
we have that here too in america and
it's really unfortunate
um so uh you know supporting the people
that are in your own
region that are producing working hard
to produce food and also keeping things
beautiful
is um and healthy is is the best i get
it
dona thank you where can people go they
want to watch the film they want to buy
them
right where do they go yeah so sacred
cow.info they can sign up we're doing
the free
global preview of the film november 22nd
through 30th
um it's going to be only that week and
then it's going to go away
it's going into distribution it'll be
available on mainstream
platforms starting in january in in
north america i don't know when it's
coming to the uk so this is your chance
so it's november
um 22nd to the 30th uh the book is
available
wherever books are sold um i have info
on on the website and then folks can
follow me
on instagram at sustainabledish
you are pounding the instagram at the
moment you've got some really cool
infographics and stuff on there
whoever's
putting your uh your he's awesome james
cooper
all the way from tasmania actually um
yeah totally he is everything will be
linked in the show notes below diana
thank you so much for today
thank you
you